well many examples I'm going to use
Irish Willy CSP which means that they
use say relations frozen functions so
but every time we see a relation we
actually think about it as a function so
it will be more convenient and uniformed
for us so every relation is actually
zero zero one function and so we usually
well every time I won't be talking about
relations it's always will be functions
okay and well I will assume that
functions are non-negative emptor so
okay so just agree on own own notation
and terminology while we are talking
about weighted constraint problems or
just the same thing partition functions
well they will be parameterized by
constraint length which is so what is a
constraint language here for us it a
constraint length which will be just any
set of functions of the type we we
talked about then the well the problem
of computing the partition function of
countess ESP over this island which okay
this number CSP of gamma
well again the instance is as usual
right so we have a bunch of variables
well we impose all these functions on
some of those variables and we multiply
them so for instance if we take a
specific some mapping from the set of
variables to our domain then the weight
of this mapping well we computers well
in the natural way we take the value of
variables apply functions to them and
multiply everything together
okay what we want to know is well the
partition function the sum of the
weights of all weapons okay this is what
we do have been doing well we lost with
the past three days so it's more or less
the same problem just the main attention
we have to notice here is isn't it okay
well I will use several running example
so again teams reduce notation well we
have seen almost all of them already
suggest introduce notation well say
counting to define some assignments of
3sat formulas it is equivalent to our
counting CSP of some constraint language
where this constraint length which
actually consists of the 4:01 functions
that are called the possible the four
possible three clauses what
okay well we don't have to be very sort
of mean in that sense for is okay okay
well another example is this counter
solutions of systems of linear equations
over finite field F well if we do it
sort of in a formal way this is the same
as counting CSP of say gamma sub F where
this constraint line which is just the
set of all zero one functions that
distinguish a solution to the system of
a equation from a non solution from a
non solution so in this case we have
only four functions in this case we have
infinitely many well if we want to be
kind of more mean as Mickey wants to be
well we can sort of reduce here
everything two equations over three
variables and so on and so on but I
don't want to do it here it's not very
important right now although I will
discuss such issues a little later well
graph harm efficiency is a very rich
source of various examples so well we
want to count from homogeneous to a
fixed graph H and clearly this is count
in CSP constraint length which is just
the edge relation of the graph nothing
else about that and again well a few
examples we have seen so far K coloring
homomorphisms into a clique so it's just
in this case this is just this equality
relation counting independent sets
should probably be undirected this H so
in the county independent set will
forget about arrow okay this is okay
again just counting how much is into
this graph and if you take the edge
relation well this is what you get okay
bipartite independent set slightly more
involved so we're talking about
bipartite graphs were making them here
then
a the preimages of these two vertices
could inform an independent set okay in
the in this case of pre images of this
vertex form an independent set okay what
else
various examples from the two-speed
model if a is a matrix 2 by 2 very small
well this matrix defined a function in a
very natural way the function it's
defined on 0 & 1 right just on binary
function defined on 0 1 so f IJ is just
the entry of the matrix look at the
matrix as the operation table of our
function various special cases like
eating for instance of this parameter
gamma in this case our matrix looks like
that - spin of alpha beta well again
very important special case where our
matrix looks like this well if you want
to generalize we can always do that also
I'm not going to use this this specific
example but if you want to generalize to
many spins or larger domains well we can
just do the same before and we get
something similar to put suitable
generalizations of the plots mode ok so
I'm going to use all those examples but
ok is finally fixed finite set so you
know for the Potts model for instance so
the spin be real numbers so I think it's
true that if they're integers and
they're very large integers
I don't think well so we have what our
functions look like like this right so
we take this small domain and mapped
real so the values are real and they can
be large and then but in what sense what
do you mean by saying that life would be
easier is there any real number how do
you find partition function problem some
sort of integration then maybe future
work no that's
yeah well that that's a kind of it makes
this different thing but kind of but it
makes sense ok anyway so maybe late the
next workshop or something ok so these
are examples I'm going to use freely but
nevertheless I will try to remind every
time I need one of them so approximation
complexity clearly the complexity of
this problem depends on gamma and we
know some examples of that say counting
the number of solutions of systems of
the equations
well none number of homomorphism series
diagonals graph that we might know by
now what they are say CSP of any gamma
where gamma consists of sort of very
highly decomposable functions that are
can be represented as product of unary
functions variables are very independent
so in its although still so easy to
count exactly so okay forget about them
if we if we take slightly more
interesting functions like for instance
easing of ferries and this is ferries
and Montgomery is greater than one or
two spin-off alpha beta where alpha and
beta belong to some interesting region
well then we know that there is an F
press also we cannot count exactly well
in some cases like well three South case
at more general well we we have very
difficult problem they are a number soft
heart for example right this means the
compliment of the interesting region
which is of course another interesting
region right well these are sort of what
we can expect more or less easy it's
slightly more difficult very difficult
well as we've heard there are some old
cases well for instance counting the
number of satisfy all independent sets
and bipartite graphs it's probably not
that promo doesn't belong to one of
those or for instance well this is
equivalently the number of CSP of this a
language which consists of one function
which is implication it's the matrix 1 1
0 1 it just calls implication they are
equivalent and no surprise there beef
equivalent but there are the audience
even the fields for instance counting
the number of q colorings of by in by
pair of bipartite graphs
it's absolutely unclear what it is
so it's something else but what exactly
nobody knows so there are there are
various things and again as was observed
before in terms of approximation
complexity the landscape is a lot more
complicated than for exact counter ok so
the general goal is quite ambitious well
it's the goal of the
of the whole workshop of course so we
want to classify the complexity of these
problems for all demo for all constraint
languages which is probably looks like
some future work but what has it been
classified so let's see that's actually
the main motivation of what I'm going to
talk about say ideally we would like to
say we have two languages and they do
have different complexities the
complexity is different and fortunately
this is a little bit too much to ask
right we need to separate a lot of
complexity classes so if you want to
solve that problem on the previous slide
in this sense well as a warm-up you
probably can prove the P doesn't equal
NP then sort of turn to serious business
like this okay well when we try to relax
it a little bit well we may try to prove
it under some assumption and indeed F
present bizarre and sat Hart accountants
at heart well can be separated on the
assumptions that say NP doesn't equal
our P or something like this but isn't
that doesn't seem to quite suffice
because for instance that BS cannot be
is not as possible by itself looks like
an assumption which is fairly feasible
but nevertheless so going this way we
may get more and more various
assumptions and where to stop it's not
it's not quite clear well so okay we can
in the Gulf even further we may look for
some kind of evidence that things are
different
well what can be evidence say one source
of such evidence is of course logic
well descriptive complex does exactly
that and we know for instance that some
good complexity classes are can be
described as expressible in some logic
for instance and P or number P can be
expressed as problems can be
characterized as problems expressible in
the same if this - a second-order logic
accounting models or formulas in such
logic
well das is well corresponds to some
convoluted logic with horrible
abbreviation I don't dare to read this
one I actually define it in one of my
talks so I'm done with my duties about
definitions I'm not going to define it
here okay this is interesting the same
if you have if you have this exact
polynomial problems can soluble exactly
in polynomial time
what is the logic for them and actually
in Rajic itself it's a very closely
related question was of great interest
so people were trying to express P
biologic the class of policies their
polynomial time solvable problems and
one of the difficult things is how do
you express in logicals in logical terms
the rank of the matrix of a matrix that
was very difficult somehow so it was
very quite elusive and for accounting
problems so boom pull one more time rank
is very important so that's exactly the
missing piece in some sense which was
missing from both decision and
accounting counting problems well people
so what was the attempt to the result
that well people started to introduce
more logical logic operations like
arrange like rank operator that would
you give it a matrix and it would return
in the rank of the matrix
okay so bump or no time well what do you
do but there are worse this is also
another Goyle of work and that's sort of
complicated ok so beauty but you want to
express it in logical way so the the
goal is like with NP for instance any
problem that the problem belongs to NP
even believe there is a formula in
existential second order logic that
expresses exactly this problem right so
I want to do the same for the class P
if I can do that the hope is well I have
different logics maybe using my computer
else kill if I can computer can start a
counter example that distinguishes these
logics and therefore proven that P does
not equal NP but what I need to do I
don't need to compute I need to Express
right so for instance I want that I want
to write a formula that would have say
five models if and only if the rank of a
given matrix is five that's exactly the
problem I cannot express in logical in
logic way porn on our time computations
that's exactly the issue well it doesn't
matter something I'd be happy with
something yeah well the probe would
deviate that's a little too far so so
far I'm described in ways I am NOT going
to follow so write say for keep by
coloring the logic is unclear to us but
we don't know what to what we can use
here for example so this is another way
we're not going to follow okay
so what else can we do well the way we
are going to follow is this what if I
try to separate problems by saying that
one cannot be reduced to another by some
class of reductions well clearly in our
case since we are talking about
approximation complexity reductions have
to be approximation preserving I'm not
going to define them here well see less
lives and others work for for all these
definitions which is pretty standard and
I'm not going to use it too much so no
definition what is the specific type of
ap reductions I am going to use F let's
teaches us there are three types of
reductions between counting problems
gadgets reductions holographic
reductions and interpolation okay so I'm
going to talk about budget reductions
for three reasons first of all
it's number one in the list well second
I don't know that much about about
holographic reductions and third
interpolation is not a participation
preserving so that's what we are going
to talk about but actually later if time
permits we will see some kind of funny
interplay between these two things
sometimes maybe a little bit more than
just that
okay so gadgets reduction so what what
do we normally understand by gadget
reductions well we have all these
functions and we want to sort of Express
a function using some gadget how do we
do that
well using some other function of course
so well okay we can select a gadget
right we use some other function I will
give one well so so far it's intuition
what we tend to understand by that so
well we have some kind of construction
using this old function G and well we
distinguish some vertices in this
construction as portals or whatever and
we hope that our construction somehow
induces what we want on the protons than
the idea is if we do everything right
and we are given a problem all over this
function f well here I assume it's
binary but it doesn't have to be binary
of course then instead of every instance
of this F I plug in my gadget and
hopefully this gives me a reduction so
clearly the trick here is to define the
gadget in the right way so what is the
right way of defining the gadget
well what I want I want that I start
with a counter in CSP and I end up with
a count in CSP right in what case I
obviously achieved that well I obviously
achieved that if my gadget is account in
CSP rather than what happens instead of
every edge here I plug some kind of more
complicated piece but nevertheless
overall well it remains a counting
system so that basically will be my
definition of a gadget a gunshot in this
sense is just an instance of counting
CSP well to be a little bit more precise
so that's what I'm trying to do right so
the all these vertices here are going to
represent variables right we're talking
about CSPs so well the portal vertices
well I will call and main variables of
three variables whatever you prefer and
the remain advanced are going to be sort
of auxiliary variables everything
happening everything is happening in a
certain domain sage okay then the way I
compute my function of using the gadget
it's just like that it's I fix the
valence of the portals Z I fix the value
of the portals and then sum up all the
way all the possible extensions to the
auxiliary variables to the observer
variables well I definitely compute some
function on interval that's this is what
I express using the gadget okay it's
more than okay not small example a
little too early so clearly we are
talking about complexity and if indeed
we have this reduction between what we
can express and where we started then
for the complexity of the problem what
is important is just what we can express
not where we started and this sort of
motivate
this whole notion of functional clothes
so what is the functional cologne I
start with some small nice constraint
line which say Delta and I construct
everything I take all functions that I
can express using gadgets from the
previous slide anything clear there will
be infinitely many of them no problem
and the result of that I'm going to call
a functional clone
so why clone well historically it was
fall from different for different types
of functions and so on but the story
I've heard clone is closed set of
operations so CL om maybe maybe not
Oh what does in the Oh baby anyway so I
call it a functional clone that includes
all functions that can be expressed
through functions from Delta well for
convenience I will also include all
constant functions we know that in for
computing partition functions we can
multiply by constants easily it doesn't
cause any problems and again for some
technical reasons I will always include
this equality function
it's just equality this is by the way
what distinguishes csps from horned so
these are kind of important here so this
is the functional clone well it's very
easy to see that if I take some set of
functions that belong to the functional
cone generated by Delta then the CSP of
gamma is ap reducible to CSP of Delta in
the sense if I am care about complexity
I only have to study close nothing else
nothing else by the way this is also an
abduction for exact counting also not
the best one for exact counting but
nevertheless well if you if we think a
little deeper about say all this small
exponential easy exponential algorithms
so then it's also number th preserving
the reduction it's because it's so
simple right we just plug in gadgets we
don't change anything so you don't
really changing it's a good one
okay small example say I start with
implication I want to show an example
how we can express things say I start
with implication that has this operation
table so implication of 0 0 is 1
implication of 0 1 is 1 and so I take a
gadget something like this for example I
put as portals I take this two variables
x and y and I impose implications well
on those of those places so if you well
if we compute it carefully then the
function we get this way is this
ferromagnetic isn't function - one two -
one two why is that for instance what is
the value of the function at 2 at 0 0 I
plug 0 here I plug 0 here now what
freedom for those variables do I have
well if both are 0 this can be either 0
1 but this one must be 0 for two options
if say this one is 0 this one is 1 this
must be 1 this one is 1 and this one is
0 so we one option since we care about
approximation sometimes we can take some
sort of limits ok so we may give some
approximate expression for for functions
so by Omega clones now I will call a
combination of the function alone and
limits what do I mean a function belongs
to belongs to this Omega clone if and
only if well it can be expressed as a
sequence of a limit of sequence of
functions each of which belongs to the
functional so I take I can take linear
unfortunately generally speaking well
limits don't have to be
don't have to behave good with respect
to approximation preserving reductions
because constructions for those
functions may be very complicated of
course so if we want to keep
reducibility then we have to restrict
ourselves to some kind of efficient
limits say we're at every function from
the sequence is somehow nicely
expressible and so on and so well in
this talk well then then we have
approximation preserving reduction if we
can express something using functional
clone and efficient limits then I have a
peer reduction between the problems
right so for the purpose of this talk I
won't make much distinction between
these two so I will just for simplicity
I will be talking about this no
efficient stuff just just amiga clones
so what I want to do is to identify and
somehow study interest in Omega clones
into the interesting in subtle sense
okay so what precisely what I want to do
I have this very large and very small
Omega clone and a lot of things in
between so the very large one is the
cone full functions the very small one
is whatever I can get from just the
quality right I want to know what in
between it will be nice to draw a
picture it's not quite possible there
are infinitely many of them we will see
it in a I don't know it's very easy to
see they're infinitely many of them so
probably picture isn't that doable but
on the other hand we don't need the
picture we want some kind of more rough
classification we want to know
complexity ultimately so
some interesting parts or important
parts or whatever this is what roughly
we want to know okay as I said I don't
have any complete picture innocent and I
have no hope to get one so what is the
rest of the talk is going to be about is
some sort of a walk in a zoo of
functional clothes of Omega clothes so
well as in a in such a walk I will try
to talk something interesting about
every species we will we will encounter
so ok can walk in the zoo
ok look right the first animal
now walk is a big one then you see is
the set of the lock super modular
functions ok what is a walk super
modular function well a function I will
restrict myself to zero two functions on
zero one domain on two element domain
that will be enough I'm not going to
look for any thousand so a function say
an airy function from zero one two
non-negative real numbers is said to be
locked super modular if if and only if
for any XY satisfies this inequality by
LSM i denote the set of all super
modular functions it includes for
instance implication ferromagnetic
easing to spin where alpha be to spin of
alpha beta where alpha beta is greater
than one
why is it important this cause well
firstly it include some interesting
functions secondly if you take the log
of such function you obtain the you get
this just super modular function which
is of course very important for
optimization so the hope is that since
it's good in terms of optimization may
be good in terms of counting as well
well it's it's yet to be seen so far but
nevertheless there is some hope that we
can do a little bit more in this case
than just in general case and of course
in this case is well that's it so we
have something in this case
well LSM is an Omega clone it's not
quite three mil by the way well I will
mention various results some of them are
video some of them are not some of them
very non-trivial but I want making
distinction between those so you you
will never know if it's it's easier or
difficult to prove
so this one is is not very difficult but
it's not trivial okay so another reason
why Allah said well why LSM is important
if you look at the conservative clones
and again we have helped about
conservative problems in this workshop
already that is those clothes that
contain all unary functions all your
functions not every comb container
okay contains all unary function but
let's look at those that do then one can
show that all clothes with this
condition either between imp and LSM
this is implication and LSM sorry oh
they are they're shown in the following
picture so it's the corner for functions
well LS them of course okay there is a
connection between them in well there is
something between them which is not
shown in this picture because we don't
know what's in between there is this
affine function which corresponds to
solving linear equations and there is a
quality and there is nothing else so
this is all if we have all unary
functions then we know everything we can
classify the complexity of everything
except for this part and even about this
part we know that this is various
equivalent what about this I don't know
if there is if there is anything and how
much is in between imp and LSM well
again we don't know all I will return to
that later
you don't know don't we don't know it
may be it may be a number soft heart
it may be BS how it may be be is easy we
don't know what doesn't that help you
come no I don't think so no it seems
nothing helps
okay what else well there are some
functions help in in general case say
one of the most general classification
results well written by obtained by
probably 70% of this room is this if I
take a conservative in the same sense
containing all the unary functions on a
finite set D then any count in CSP is
either F principal or numbers at heart
or in AP introduced but with a cone
between imp and LSM it's not clear
what's between them so if we know well
we could complete this classification a
good chunk of the goal of this workshop
would be completed so yes Ella some are
important okay I don't know we don't
need to know what Fourier coefficients
are I just need some piece of
terminology for that well for a function
I can compute the Fourier transform of
this function and well Fourier transform
is a function itself it's also an airy
well its values are also real often
don't have to be non-negative even if
you start with some new negative
function okay I call a specific value of
this Fourier transform and even three a
coefficient if the Hamming weight the
number of months and this value is even
well I can III called old if the Hamming
weight is old well I will need these two
things somehow I will need these two
things somehow okay
calls that are given by all three
equations let's take all functions whose
Fourier coefficients are non-negative oh
why not
well let's take those who's even Fourier
coefficients are non-negative but odd
ones are non positive
two sets of functions why are they
interesting well again they they contain
some interesting cases they contain some
interesting cases say P F contains imp
and everything and this to spin in this
interesting case which is slightly
weaker condition than alpha times beta
is greater than 1 they are only the
close which is good and we know a little
bit about them and we know a little bit
about them say if you take binary
functions from PF then there is enough
press problem well for instance this
gives immediate is that to spin off
alpha beta in this case is expressible
well it's unpublished is it ok so this
explains this question mark here so
Colin pulled it but didn't publish
somehow okay now look left so dual
functions well I say that the function
is self dual if for any assignment F of
the assignment in d5 flip every zero and
one in the assignment Devere is the same
again if you look at what people are
doing well in this workshop in
particular most of talks are concerned
with solve dual functions ok SD is the
set of self dual functions and well it
includes all these in call to spin alpha
beta and many other interesting things
well it's somehow related to all three
coefficients say all three coefficients
of functions from as d equal to 1 to 0-3
how can we use of dual functions again
we don't know much about that well for
instance it's very difficult to get to
get results even about this classes and
these are only small part of of SD but
nevertheless
of course as the itself is hard but
maybe some fragments of it may be
interesting
well there is a kind of interesting use
of those self dual functions so first of
all in its in some sense
well it's some Omega clone in some sense
it's very big its maximal if you add any
function to SD which is not as D itself
then you get all functions you can
express any function at all so it's very
big the other hand it's very small
because it's 8k its generated by any
anti fair isn't function so it's somehow
very special in a sense somehow very
special but it also helps to prove
various since well for instance let's
look at this trick that I call dual
ization here say we have this set latest
of all clones okay and I take this
interval which starts at SD and well
everything between SD and equality what
I can do I can convert any function to a
self-dual one just multiplying by this
Supino variable so multiplying them
clearly at least one is self dual what
does it mean in terms of this picture it
means that I map all well the colorful
functions using that into the clones of
dual functions and the clones of
equalities okay well they they remain
the same
okay fine if I take imp
the LSM well this is it to see that I
apply the same thing to Ellison for
instance I get again the whole clone of
absorb dual functions if I apply imp
well I again again just get this
equality nothing else now there is an
interesting clone here so dual with
positive Fourier coefficients again its
maximal here so this is a simple
interval there is nothing in between
let's take its pre image what is it well
it turns out it's something known so
this is the only known clone so far
between imp and LSM and you can
construct it this way
well maybe if you know more from here
maybe you can construct more there I
don't know
that's why we don't know much about
what's below SD okay rope cloth
something expressible made by mage gates
let's M do you know the set of all
functions it's one of the dinosaurs from
Jurassic Park the one which spits some I
have no 82 son felices no well it's
resurrected right like the dinosaur okay
so let's you know let him do know the
Joseph all function whose Fourier
transform is expressible as a mage gate
with positive weights again it's
something that has been looked at of I
wouldn't say it was thoroughly studied
also some variations of this class
author are very thoroughly studied for
instance those that expressed by plain
image gates with possible negative
coefficients well we know a lot about
this one
see I didn't function that satisfies
certain identities and so on and so on
well another similar thing that well we
may be interested in in the class of
functions that for who's who the Fourier
transform is expressible by plenum
educates and but using only positive
ways well include some kind of
interesting functions for instance this
for air is symmetric function with the
signature so the value depends only on
the Hamming weight if Hamming weight is
zero then it's five if it's having
weight is one is it's one and so on
it doesn't look some interesting
functions this one and this one a
functional close which is a game kind of
an odd thing if you think about it
because we are important conditions from
the Fourier transform but since we know
so much about
if it's an Omega cone we don't know what
happens if we take limits but since then
P is given by identities since n P is
given by identity as well okay we know
that it is an Omega claw okay it's time
to draw some pictures perhaps just to
classify things we know so far
again we start with something big with
something small there is this threat
between EQ and all functions related to
LS l we have this positive or three-year
negative for three year self dual age
which is the same as isn't well we have
an interesting intersection which is
just just below as the well we have this
cone generated by M and M P it should
probably be here not quite here I'm not
sure about this connection if it should
be here here by the way and the
intersection so that's what we have so
far okay I have two more animals
probably we can look at one of them and
then I show the final picture fairy
isn't small well first of all we know
that very thing is can be reduced in the
holographic sense to the counting of
even sub drops but actually it turns out
that Oxford that they also generate the
same clone so somehow holographic
reduction here gadgets reduction is the
same so you can you can work hard or do
nothing but you get the same result it's
really tiny it's really tiny it's below
in the temp it impairs we know now it's
very very low with low here okay it's
now the final picture all right
the final picture is this so well this
is what I've shown so far well I also
have this clone of monotone functions
and various variations of monotone
functions like like this that are
parameterize by a by a non-negative real
number and for each non-negative real
number you have a separate clone so this
thick line means that it's well I I just
I just make all the all the continuum
points here right so this is this is how
they okay I probably won't be talking
about the list of open problems since we
have this uncountable all that is we
have uncountable many problems and so I
couldn't make a list but
for this ambassador why do you have a
fully after feeding get a magical time
why do this what do we do that yes
exactly
no I forgot
why we don't do that so it's a kind of
strange coincidence that after four year
did we know so if you look at my
tutorial of the bootcamp well wipe up I
I discussed that in substantial details